[Music]
Garrett didn't you look when you bought
the overalls why did you get 44 by 33
these ones say 3655 Ren's in here this
is the front this is the front end from
hey 44 by 33 to soften the face dude
actually this kind of it works
ma'am I know still already Mario Luigi
and Mario and Peach you look fat I love
archery I love airsoft only there's a
way to be able to shoot at your friends
with bows and arrows without killing
them Oh baby
this is our tree attack like a heart
attack but our truth so many bows in
here you know post for all my friends we
haven't even finished filling up the
buckets yet and we already encountered
our first problem we have about a half
bottle of bleach left and there's way
too much water in quarts flower bro
you're not you took a huge dump behind
you got my bill sorry oh come oh my god
six years ago I caught a tiny lizard
there's these little lizards in
California I picked this stick up to
give it to Rocky it just grabbed him and
he's in my hand right now I'm so happy
right now
this little guy he's not happy I'm gonna
put him in a really big cage and he's
gonna have everything he wants except
for freedom which is the only thing he
will want we've let these genes fit in
this bucket with bleach in them for
about two hours now we got some advice
from D and he says that once it's dry
and ready to be dyed to add a lot of
salt
[Music]
there you go LAN down heavy just just
take it easy because you're not on the
number you don't need to be on a number
[Music]
save it up demon of demon of the land
steaming I'll steam it up steam in a
steaming up the land we still have def
leppard overall but I think if we die on
the work I think with with a deep enough
with enough purple the work fine Wow and
it's a brand new map dude there's like
you can get hiney ho I won't do full
power maybe I will
oh no it seriously feels like someone's
it's like a little kids like punches you
with this little hand ready
[Music]
I got